we are thrilled about our next guest
she's the queen of the summer novel her
name is ellen hildebrand the
best-selling author is known for
bringing her readers to the sandy shores
of nantucket island place she knows very
well in massachusetts her 28th novel is
out today it's called the hotel
nantucket it follows the new general
manager of the hotel as she tries to
revive its bruised image fresh off her
own breakup ellen joins us once again in
the studio it's always good to have you
here so you see we always have all your
books up so you can see your life your
life on the pages we're going to get a
bigger wall eventually i know that's a
lot i sat down and you looked at it what
do you think ellen when you look at the
wall of books it's one of my favorite
things when i think
it's my life and pictures and i mean
it's it's humbling and it's amazing and
i'm glad that i mean i i used my time i
feel like i use my time well you really
have okay so right before break it said
i said it includes infidelity and i love
a good infidelity story and shauna uh
our big cheese around here said you like
an infidelity story i go yeah because
listen as someone who's had a cheater
cheater pumpkin eater husband i'm always
fascinated by how they got caught why
they did it how did it end up what was
the bottom line you know i
but this is a rip-roaring opening to the
book right i mean look the way the way
he gets caught is great it's the way
that he gets caught yeah and i said the
way that the woman sets him up to get
caught it's something only a woman could
think of and it made me think what's
going on in your life ella
exactly you thought of those little
nuggets i know well i'm always thinking
of the twist and you need and i need to
i've written all these novels so i need
to do something different with each book
so as i'm thinking about like how people
get caught
you know i'm also thinking about 2022
and of course it's always cell phones
and
no this was good yeah but the hotel
nantucket you really do love the place
where you live but what was so
attractive to you about the hotel
nantucket well i think you thought it
was a good storyline because we've been
in a pandemic i really wanted my readers
to feel like they were taking a vacation
at a five-star hotel i wanted to
transport them but i had to create i had
to really build it from scratch it is
based on a real hotel the nantucket
hotel in nantucket but i created a
fictional history i did a deep dive into
interior design and i like designed the
hotel myself and then of course i had to
people it with a staff and there's a
ghost story i i don't really like ghost
stories i know no so i mean i like this
yeah i'm not really a ghost story person
i'm not a spooky person but what i
wanted was an omniscient narrator who
could see into the rooms
who could see the staff and the guests
coming and going and could be you know
our eyes and ears and so that is grace
yeah our ghost it's really good no
really good this book includes playlists
uh musical playlists which is great it's
just a little nugget that kind of adds
to the layering of the characters but
how did you come up with these playlists
though so the playlists are a mix of
sort of music that i listened to growing
up but i have children that are in their
early 20s and late teens and so i texted
my kids and i'm like give me the best
breakup songs and they were like they're
really good
do you have a breakup playlist a love
playlist yes and sort of a recovery from
breakup play yes yeah there are three
you covered all errors you did a great
job thank you so speaking of looking at
these books and the story of your life
uh eight years ago so about eight books
ago you were on this show talking to
gail in fact uh about being diagnosed
with breast cancer uh you're now a
survivor no nate she was here the day
before that's right we're having a
double mastectomy dale that's tony i
mean oh did i look
okay sorry sorry well you all look alike
but tony she was here the day before you
were having a radical
day before i couldn't believe that you
were sitting here at the table talking
to us i know eight years ago and one of
the things i mean i i feel like it was
another lifetime ago but one of the
things i've done is that i've really
devoted myself to speaking around the
country i've been involved with the bcrf
and then more recently the national
breast cancer foundation i did a
handwritten letter that went out in
their hope kits to all the people who
are suffering so i've really tried to
give back and use my diagnosis for good
well it's your 28th book she says she's
stopping after book number 30. i don't
believe i don't believe it i don't
believe it either cannot do it you're
going to write a book with your daughter
really excited about that thank you
ellen congratulations thank you this is
great it's called the hotel nantucket
it's on sale wherever you like to buy
your books it's so so good we'll be
right back